Matthew as well as Matthews in
Washington DC I Matthew how are you
better than I deserve what's up so
complicated situations outside to keep
it simple I am having some issues with
asking me for money over the past thirty
I went back and actually looked the
other day to tell her over the past
thirty days I have sent her over nine
hundred dollars and my monthly income is
about nine hundred dollars right now cuz
I work part-time I'm still in school he
doesn't the problem is she doesn't
flat-out ask me for money it's more or
less she'll make we'll be talking about
whatever cuz you know we have a really
close relationship I'm thankful for that
but we'll be talking about you know
whatever is going on in our day or
what's stressing us out or you know just
having conversation and she'll mention
something like I say hey what are you
doing for dinner
how old is an inch twenty-five do you
live at home he kind of got this is a
little complicated
I had a worker's comp entry that
completely like threw everything off I
should have been moved out like two or
three years ago are you here no not 100%
no yes you have to work at a desk
instead of doing what I did before and
you made nine hundred dollars a month at
twenty five years old
it's just a part-time job and so I can
finish finish up my degree next year and
buy something regular you're studying
okay and what did you agree in is going
to be in the business administration
with a minor in finance
okay very good okay so the goal is to
get out have a career make good money
and get out of the house that's that's
like the two-year goal the end of next
summer I plan on think down with school
and and you know land the big plans a
big job and get out okay I got you so in
the meantime you've just got a
boundary issue with her and it sounds
like the way you're describing it and if
I'm if I read you're wrong you can tell
me but like that your close relationship
with her is being taken advantage of no
she's taking advantage of it she knows
that I'm a generous person especially
with family you know it's if they need
help with something and I can do it
without putting myself in situation I'm
going to struggles and I'm going to help
them always been that type so what was
your question how do how do I continue
to be yes supportive and helpful and a
financial aid to my family and so
everything gets figured out you can't
under ninety nine hundred dollars a
month the week the week can't lift the
broken person the strong can lift the
broken person and financially you're
weak you make $900 a month you're 25
years old it's not your job to lift your
mother so it's okay you didn't do
anything wrong
you're not being immoral you're not
being lacking in generosity you know
your mom needs to work on her life the
fact that she's going to her kids for
money says she's got issues but know
you're not responsible for her you're 25
years old if you won't be generous a
little bit fine but it's out of control
is what you're telling me